Welcome to Looper.
I'm Brian Rubin.
Today, we're talking all about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
You know, the MCU has brought us some legendary
villains over the last 10 years or so: Agatha
Harkness, Killmonger, and of course, the big
purple guy, Thanos.
The MCU has also brought us some less legendary
bad guys, guys like Yellowjacket, Malekith,
and Garry Shandling.
I'm joined today by Tom and Nina to try and
answer the question, who are the best and
worst villains the Marvel Cinematic Universe
could introduce in phase four.
Tom, Nina, hello.
Hey, how are you?
Hi.
Good.
Are you implying that Garry Shandling [inaudible]
of us?
I'm just saying that as far as a villain is
concerned, not the top tier bad guy kind of
thing.
No.
I love Garry Shandling, but is he...
Anyway, you know what I'm saying.
I don't know, did you ever see Mixed Nuts?
That's in darkness, man.
Rest in peace [inaudible].
So Tom-
Who are the best and worst villains that Marvel
could introduce in phase four?
I'm glad that you asked that, Brian, because
I was thinking about this just the other night
while I was writing down ideas-
That's so weird.
... because you told me to.
Yeah.
Who are the best and worst villains that we
can bring back into the MC?
Personally, I think in terms of the best villain...
What makes a good villain?
Is there an objective answer?
But Vincent D'Onofrio from Daredevil.
That would be my number one top pick.
If we could bring one guy back, the intensity
that that guy brought to the role, just spectacular,
practically alien.
So weird and creepy.
I love the guy.
You're thinking about villains that could
come back into the MCU, is that where we're
going?
I don't know.
Have we determined whether or not we're [inaudible]
Netflix as stuff that happened in the MC Universe?
That's a good point.
Netflix is definitely stuff that happened.
My particular question here was what villains
could they bring into the MCU from the comics?
But I think it's totally valid to ask what
villains that we've had before could come
back too.
All villains are on the table as long as they
are Marvel villains.
Got it.
So in terms of fresh to the MCU, at a very
personal level, I would love to see Sentinels
pop up at some point.
Those were one of the first terrifying nightmares
that I remember having as a kid.
It was those big purple that get the things.
Before I die, I would love to see Sentinels
done right on the big screen, just like giant,
terrifying, [crosstalk] monsters.
Are you in favor of a Master Mold, perhaps?
I don't know if it's dark and raised.
I'd say go get it checked out.
But you know, man.
Master Mold, of course, is the giant mama
Sentinel that makes the big Sentinels, but
they're it's baby Sentinels.
Master Mold is a classic X-Men villain.
Don't talk to me like I'm people that don't
know Master Mold.
I know you know Master Mold.
I'm trying to explain who Master Mold might
be.
We're trying to translate, Tom.
Yes.
Anyway, you want to see the Sentinels.
You want to see Vincent D'Onofrio.
Tell us more about the villains you'd like
to see.
My only other big thing is there's a caveat
and I'd like to come back around to it in
a minute.
I feel like we've got to see Galactus at some
point, right?
Yes.
I think so, yeah.
It's one of the last really big, recognizable
way over the top villains that Marvel hasn't
really touched too much.
We know that they haven't been able to touch
Galactus because up until very recently, Galactus,
as a member of the Fantastic Four cast of
characters, he's a Fantastic Four villain
first and foremost, Marvel Studios hasn't
had the rights to use Galactus because they
were owned by Fox.
Now Marvel Disney owns Fox, and so that opens
things up for guys like the Sentinels who
were also X-Men, also owned by Fox for the
movie rights.
Now Sentinels, now Galactus are both available
to come into the Marvel Universe.
I 100% agree.
Galactus was on my list that...
You can see he's right there above my head,
watching over all of us, Galactus, my friend,
my best friend.
I like to think he always is.
Yeah.
Tom, do you want to explain who Galactus is
and just what his deal is?
I'm glad that you ask, Brian.
You know the song, Food, Glorious Food from
the Oliver musical?
He's that, but he's a person.
He is a semi timeless entity from a universe
that...
They get destroyed before ours was ever created.
He's all that's left of this other universe
and he loves eating planets, man.
He's all about eating planet.
He loves two things.
He loves a good helmet and he loves a delicious
planet sandwich.
I love how his helmet has a little brim on
it on the front end-
It does.
... like a little baseball cap.
But why?
I also like the little mask.
I think that's my favorite part is he's got
the little domino mask-
Just a little domino mask.
... scoped into it just to protect his identity.
[crosstalk]
His original design, he had a big belt with
a G on it and bike shorts.
Yeah, he did.
In short shorts.
Nice.
Bike shorts, they're making a comeback, so
that could work.
They're all the rage out in the outer reaches
of space.
Yeah.
You would know this if you ever watched [inaudible].
True.
Did you have any other villains for your list,
Tom?
Not for the best ones, no.
Okay.
Nina, what about your best villain that the
MCU could bring in in phase four?
I've only got the one and while I was doing
research for this, I stumbled on her.
I wasn't that familiar, so I did some research
at...
I stumbled upon Amora, also known as the Enchantress,
who is a Thor villain.
Yes.
And she is cool.
I really loved Cate Blanchett's Hela.
I really love a good female antagonist and
she sounds awesome.
I think that having Chris Hemsworth have a
really seductive villain to play off of could
be tremendously fun, especially if Taika Waititi
keeps directing Thor movies.
I have the worst news, Nina.
They did that on Agents of Shield.
Didn't they bring her in in Agents of Shield?
Oh, I didn't-
Was she Enchantress on Agents of Shield?
I think she was in Agents of Shield but she
got the whole like Power Rangers treatment
that that show gave to so many of its characters.
No, I don't think you're right.
I could be wrong.
We're going to look this up in a few minutes.
I would love to be wrong.
I think it was a different-
Please be wrong because I was really jazzed
about this.
I know.
I hate disappointing Nina.
I think it's a different character from the
comics that was Enchantress adjacent, if I
recall correctly, I will admit it's been a
long time since I've watched Agents of Shield.
Same.
I will also admit I didn't finish Agents of
Shield.
Nobody did, man.
Same.
[crosstalk] couldn't finish Agents of Shield.
Yeah.
I got forgot that it was a show, to be honest,
until right now when you said Agents of Shield.
I'm really sorry.
Yeah.
I'm almost positive it was a different character
that wasn't quite the Enchantress, but she
did basically everything the Enchantress did.
But with that said-
I want to believe you.
... but let's also be real here though.
Even if Agents of Shield did do that, they
also did the Inhumans and then they made an
Inhuman show anyway-
Right.
That's true.
... that was totally different and divorced
from everything happening [crosstalk].
Right.
And if we're talking Vincent D'Onofrio, then
we can talk the Enchantress too.
I think that's fair game.
Totally fair.
They could just say it was a different Enchantress.
It was a different incarnation of the Enchantress-
Right.
... if they even acknowledge that it happened
on Agents of Shield at all.
So far, the only acknowledgement-
True.
... of anything that happened on Agents of
Shield in the movies was the inclusion of
TV Jarvis from the Peggy [coast].
Oh, yeah.
Oh, right.
That's it.
Yeah.
Because he's great.
That's true.
So there's room for Enchantress.
I love the Enchantress.
She's a great villain.
She's great, yeah.
Reading more about her, I was trying to think
of who would play her?
Just trying to, maybe not the right age, but
a Laura Dern-type would be really fun and
campy in that role.
Laura Dern would be great.
Yeah.
My mind went to January Jones.
Your mind always goes to January.
No, that's good.
Every month of the year.
When she's given room to play around in a
role like on Last Man on Earth, she really
have a good time.
Yes.
That would be fun.
She's so fun.
She's so good.
If she's allowed to let loose and just be
weird and fun, she could be amazing.
Yes.
She wasn't very good as Emma Frost, but no
one was good in that movie, which was...
Right.
Which movie was that?
No, that was First Class.
That was First class.
First Class, yeah.
Let me back up.
Some people were good in that movie.
I do think-
[crosstalk] really have much to do besides
that [inaudible], now we're close.
Yes, that's true.
Right.
I'm going to walk back my statement slagging
off all of First Class.
Yes.
It was some good-
I'm going to fan cast and [inaudible] too.
I'm going to pick January Jones with an assist
from you.
Yes.
I'm going to say her.
You've got it.
It's yours.
She's as good as cast.
Perfect.
Somebody call Marvel.
Whoever plays her, as long as she keeps the
same pants that she had back in the day.
I want you to create her original costume,
the best pant.
We can go on and on about Galactus' pants,
Enchantress' pants, unbelievable.
She had very fancy green pants and [crosstalk]
She had the fanciest pants.
They have a loopy zone.
So my pick, not that either of you ask, is-
We didn't.
I came armed with two because I thought someone
might say one of them and I was right.
So Tom said Galactus.
My pick is Doctor Doom who up until now, also
was a Fantastic Four villain, so off limits
to Marvel Studios, has appeared in two different
iterations of the Fantastic Four franchise.
Both times, not the best.
But walk these words back, man.
Let's not say things that we can't take back.
You're a big fan of the depiction of Doctor
Doom in one of the previous Fantastic Four
movies?
You know what?
This is a me thing.
I don't want to bring me things into...
I don't hate the first two, the ones from
the mid-2000s.
They're not great.
I'm not going to say good.
I'm not going to say good, but cute, enjoyable.
So you're not going to backfire, you're just
going to-
No!
... lightly defend.
I'm going to prod at defending the story,
Fantastic Four's.
My issue with the Doctor Doom realization
in those movies specifically, is that it's
only a fraction of the kind of great stuff
you can do with a guy like Doctor Doom.
Totally.
Even if the actor portraying him did a good
job with the material, and there are definitely
things in those two Fantastic Four movies,
and even though the Josh Trank one, there's
stuff in those movies that I think are cool.
They're good.
They're interesting.
Chris Evans is, as the Human Torch, was actually
really excellent.
When he was cast as Captain America, I was
like, "That's great.
This guy can act.
He's awesome."
So Doctor Doom, that actor whose name escapes
me, he's fine for that movie, but overall,
what I want out of a Doctor Doom is a totally
ego maniacal Machiavellian ruler of a European
country named Latveria that's always weirdly
stuck in the dark ages and always all the
villagers have pitchforks and torches at any
moment.
What is with that?
That's what it looks like there.
No way.
That's just what it is.
I never thought about that.
But yeah, no, you're right.
The villagers always look like they're stuck
in the medieval caste system.
That's what he likes.
Do they also have robots that are indiscernible
from living beings?
Yeah.
He has a whole army of Doombots that are just...
Marvel Comics has made an industry out of
explaining a way inconsistencies with his
character by saying, "Oh, that was a Doombot
that thought it was the real Doctor Doom.
I'm the real Doctor Doom."
So there's so much room for mistakes.
Exactly.
You can do whatever you want and then [crosstalk]
And this is the character that you want to
bring in into the MC Universe.
[crosstalk]
What I like about him is that he is so purely
and deliciously into his thing.
He's the hero of his own story and he is the
most heroic hero.
He has what's called main character syndrome,
where you're like, "I am the protagonist."
Yeah, [crosstalk]
Yeah.
Whenever Doctor Doom shows up, the story gets
better.
Whenever the heroes have to fight Doctor Doom,
it's a great story.
It doesn't matter what Doctor Doom is doing,
he's just fun.
He just improves the material.
He's just so great.
I just love the way he refers to himself in
the third person.
Again, these are things that don't necessarily
have to come to the movie, but I do think
that if you can make a guy like Iron Man believable
and interesting and entertaining, you can
make a guy like Doctor Doom threatening and
yet still entertaining.
He can have that charisma, that ego, and still
be a menacing bad guy.
If anyone can do it, Marvel Studios can do
it.
So I want Doctor Doom.
So who do you want playing Doctor Doom?
Who has that level of charisma?
I saw somebody fan cast, Giancarlo Esposito,
and I thought that that was pretty spot on.
That's pretty good.
That would be fun.
That would actually be fantastic.
I don't know if he wants to spend his entire
life playing enigmatic, largely silent villains,
but if he does, he will be terrific at that.
I think that's kind of his thing, yeah.
But that's a perfect cast.
I didn't have an answer ready, but as soon
as you said that, I was like, "Yeah, that'll
work."
Yeah.
That would be great.
No, I think he'd be great.
I'd pay big money for that.
Who has the charisma to play Galactus?
We never got around to that.
Another good question.
I wish I'd thought of the casting aspect of
this.
Who has the charisma to play Galactus?
That's what I'm asking you, Brian.
How funny is Galactus?
Is he funny?
No.
No, he's a hoot.
He's always like, "Oh, I'm hungry."
He's very pretentious.
He's always very...
Gosh.
That's the kind of question that's really
difficult to answer because if you had said,
"Who should play Thanos?" we never would have
said, "Josh Brolin."
No, it's true.
Right.
It's an insane answer.
Frankly, the Thanos that we got in the movies
is pretty different from the Thanos from the
comics.
That's a good point.
Obviously, whatever they do with him, they'll
do something good.
Part of me wants to say Josh Brolin, because
he's already been a great Thanos, so he'd
probably do a great Galactus, but that would
be silly.
What about John Cena?
Sure, why not?
Oh, spectacular.
Just give it to The Rock.
Let The Rock.
Yeah.
Let The Rock play all of them.
Can you smell what Galactus is cooking?
It's [crosstalk].
[crosstalk], because he's so hungry.
Because he's hungry, yeah.
Love this.
I think that's the answer.
I think we've come up with it.
Who would be the worst villains that Marvel
could bring into MCU phase four?
Nina.
I have two.
One of them is Egghead, a character I didn't
know existed, who is just like a quiet, dweeby
person who is from the Ant-Man comics.
I believe he gets murdered pretty quickly
by Hawkeye.
Let's not bury the lead, Nina.
What does his head look like?
He's just called Egghead because he likes
studying.
That's it.
That's not even a good name.
He has a normal head.
Then the other one I found which is just horrifying
is Carlos Cabrera or Gamecock, who is a chicken
man that fights Captain America.
Shut your mouth.
What?
You know it's real.
How do I not know about this?
I don't know.
He is a minor antagonist in the Captain America
comics.
His name is Gamecock and he's a chicken man.
Gamecock.
I can say it seems unlikely that they're going
to bring Gamecock.
I really hope so.
It seems unlikely that they're going to bring
Batroc the Leaper into this either, but here
we are.
Yeah.
I guess you're right.
So don't count out Gamecock.
I don't want to say that.
I would prefer to count it out.
I went looking.
I went poking through marvel.com and all this
stuff and I just saw chicken man and I was
like, "That can't be good."
I did some research and yeah, in fact, he
is a chicken man.
He fights Captain America unsuccessfully a
couple of times.
I don't want to see any part of that.
I don't want to see a Falcon-Chicken fight.
He didn't win?
Yeah, no.
In a shocking turn of events, the chicken
man didn't beat America's superhero.
I know it's weird.
You're telling me the chicken dude tried to
fight the leader of the Avenger?
That didn't pan out.
Did not end well for him.
[Crosstalk]
[crosstalk], son of a gun.
So those are my picks.
I feel pretty good about them.
Tom, who would be-
Yes.
... your worst villain to add to the MCU phase
four?
I'm going to make a difficult call here.
Okay.
Galactus.
Okay, please explain.
You got to understand I-
You just hurt Brian's feelings.
Hey, I hurt my feelings too.
I'm so excited to see Galactus.
I would love to see Galactus.
He was on my list of the best characters to
bring in.
The problem that I think we're going to run
into at this point is that we're running out
of recognizable, back in the day comic book
characters.
You know what I mean?
We're down to like half of the original Avengers,
maybe two out of six, something like that.
Something like that, yeah.
I don't know if it's going to have the same
gravitas if you'd bring in great, big, bucket-headed,
planet-eater guy, and then the only people
that you have left to fight in my way, White
Vision,-
Well, don't forget.
Now, hang on though.
Winter Soldier.
I'm going to subvert this though.
By all means.
Galactus doesn't have to just fight the Avengers.
Galactus is a Fantastic Four villain.
He certainly is.
We know a Fantastic Four movie at the end
of phase four.
So if you tell me that you're going to introduce
a Fantastic Four movie and then at the end
of that movie, you don't have a tease for
Galactus is coming and that's our big arc
over the next several years to prepare for
the coming of Galactus-
I would love to believe that you're right,
Brian, but at the same time, we sat through
all Wanda Vision and at the end, what that
was leading to was [crosstalk].
She was reading.
Yeah.
RIP Ralph Bohner, gone but not forgotten.
I do feel a little bit like maybe, Kevin's
messing with us now.
Maybe he got through the main story that he
wanted to tell and despite having a staple
of characters that would absolutely carry
the franchise for another 20 years, maybe
at this point, he's just like he's reached
a point in his career-
Screw it, yeah.
... where he's okay with just kind of, "Nah."
He's just winging it now.
It's just coasting for the next 25 years.
Doctor Bong.
Here comes Doctor Bong.
Doctor Bong is a Howard the Duck villain with
a bell for a head.
You bet he is.
I don't want to see that either.
[crosstalk] one of the most untenable storylines
from the early 2000s, I want to say.
Wait until you're not on your work computer
and go look it up.
It's amazing.
Oh man.
So my pick for worst villain that they could
possibly introduce is another old, Fantastic
Four villain.
He goes by the Trapster, but his original
name...
Tom, you look very excited.
You know who I'm talking about.
Is it Paste-Pot Pete?
It's Paste-Pot Pete.
Paste-Pot Pete.
I stumbled across Paste-Pot Pete as well.
Paste-Pot Pete carries a bucket of glue-
I bet he does.
... and he shoots the glue with his glue gun
and he fights the Human Torch and it's a close
one.
It's close.
The Human Torch almost doesn't win.
So Paste-Pot Pete is basically just like a
mom who shops at Marshalls for [crosstalk].
It's really good glue.
It's really good.
They have glue at Marshalls.
Right.
I love the defense of Galactus was we're going
to bring in the Fantastic Four, but 25% of
that team just almost got taken out by glue.
By glue guy.
It's fireproof glue, that's why.
If it's fireproof, [crosstalk].
I was being stupid.
It was tough.
So the backstory of Paste-Pot Pete is apparently,
he was a brilliant scientist who developed
a super duper effective, awesome glue.
But instead of saying, "I should be in business.
I should do things with my glue that are business-y,"
he says, "I'm going to Rob a bank and then
I'm going to try to steal a missile."
Luckily for the bank, the Human Torch was
online to access his savings account that
day.
So as it happened, the two of them tussled,
and after he defeated Paste-Pot Pete, he forever
harbored a grudge, excuse me, against the
Human Torch.
There we go.
Eventually, he changed his name to the Trapster.
He still shoots glue out of his gloves.
So he changed his name, not as gimmick.
He was like, "This is working great, but [crosstalk].
I think he does different traps.
The problem isn't the glue.
The problem is the appearance, the presentation.
It's the branding.
Right.
Anyway, I feel like that would be maybe not
the best choice for MCU phase four.
I would not want to see that.
There's that.
I love that.
This is the Paste-Pot Pete.
Thanks for joining us.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single episode.